Das Ulmer Münster – eindrucksvoll und
einzigartig.
Das hier ist der höchste Kirchturm der Welt!
Warum ist der eigentlich so hoch?
Wie fühlt es sich an, um den Turm
herumzufliegen?
Warum wird hier ständig gebaut?
Und wie schnell schaff ich‘s nach oben?
Der höchste Kirchturm der Welt wirft einige
Fragen auf.
Für die Antworten steige ich zunächst nach
ganz oben. 768 Stufen zu Fuß.
Einen Aufzug gibt es nicht.
In 143 Metern Höhe - dem Himmel also schon
ziemlich nahe -
wartet Pfarrer Peter Schaal-Ahlers auf mich.
Manche sagen, es ist wie ein Fingerzeig,
dass da oben nochmal im Himmel
‘ne andere Dimension ist.
Aber das hört sich mir sehr fromm,
eigentlich fast zu fromm an, um wahr zu sein.
161,53 Meter misst der Kirchturm.
Weltrekord.
Und das in Ulm: Die Stadt hat gerade mal
125.000 Einwohner.
Sie liegt im Süden Deutschlands direkt an der
Donau.
Einst war Ulm eine mächtige und
wohlhabende Stadt.
Ulmer Barchent, ein hochwertiger Stoff, war
weltweit gefragt.
Das Münster zeugt noch heute vom einstigen
Reichtum.
Nicht nur der Turm ist gigantisch, sondern
auch der gotische Kirchenraum.
Ich bin einer von rund einer Million Besuchern
jährlich
und bestaune die sakralen Kunstschätze.
Es ist das größte evangelische Gotteshaus
Deutschlands.
Das Allerwesentlichste ist, dass es eine
Bürgerkirche ist.
Und das heißt also, nicht eine Kirche, nicht
ein Bischof hat die Idee gehabt,
diese Kirche zu bauen, sondern die Bürger
selber.
Und man sagt, das Selbstbewusstsein der
Ulmer sei so hoch wie der Kirchturm.
Das Gründungsrelief zeigt die
Grundsteinlegung im Jahr 1377.
Schon sehr früh hatten die Ulmer die Vision,
den höchsten Kirchturm der Welt zu
errichten.
Doch 1543 ging das Geld aus. Der Bau
wurde gestoppt.
Erst 300 Jahre später wurde die Kirche in
ihrer jetzigen Form fertiggestellt.
'Fertiggestellt' ist für Michael Hilbert allerdings
ein Fremdwort.
Als Münsterbaumeister ist er dafür zuständig,
die Bausubstanz der Kirche zu erhalten.
In der Münsterbauhütte sind 24 Mitarbeiter
damit beschäftigt,
jeden einzelnen Stein zu prüfen, zu
restaurieren oder auszutauschen.
Für die Steinmetze eine filigrane Arbeit.
Wenn man den Anspruch hat, sag ich mal, so
ein Gebäude
- und das ist ja ein nationales Denkmal -,
eben in diesem Zustand zu restaurieren,
dann muss man auch bis
in den letzten Winkel
diese Detailverliebtheit an den Tag legen.
Das Ulmer Münster aus der Vogelperspektive
zu erleben: eigentlich unmöglich.
Doch mit dem Ganzkörper-Flugsimulator
"Birdly" und einer VR-Brille wird es möglich.
Ich fliege virtuell durch Ulm im Jahre 1890
und komme dem Münster nah.
Sehr nah sogar.
Wahnsinn! Wahnsinn! Wirklich irre!
Vor allem: Ich komme mir jetzt wirklich so vor,
als sei ich plötzlich
wieder in einem völlig anderen Raum wieder.
Also, dass ich jetzt wieder hier bin, da muss
ich mich erst einmal dran gewöhnen.
Zurück im realen Ulmer Münster.
Viele Besucher kommen ja ausschließlich, um
den Kirchturm zu besteigen.
Und manche machen sogar einen Sport
daraus.
Beim jährlichen Ulmer Münsterturmlauf
rennen sie um die Wette:
560 Stufen bis auf 102 Meter.
Der Gewinner des vergangenen Jahres hat
2:36 Minuten gebraucht.
Da kann ich leider nicht mithalten.
Ich hab‘s geschafft. In fünf Minuten.
Doch hochlaufen, ob schnell oder langsam,
lohnt sich allemal.
Es gibt ja wesentlich höher gelegene
Aussichtspunkte auf der Welt.
Aber das Ulmer Münster hochzulaufen
mit all der Geschichte drum herum,
das ist schon was sehr, sehr Besonderes.
Auch wenn er vielleicht nicht für immer
der höchste Kirchturm der Welt bleiben wird,
eins wird das Ulmer Münster immer sein:
herausragend.